es posible que a usted o un ser querido
le hayan diagnosticado leucemia este
video lo ayudará a entender algunas
opciones de tratamiento
disponibles la leucemia Es un cáncer que
se origina en las células sanguíneas
mientras estas se forman usualmente en
los glóbulos
blancos en la leucemia las células que
forman la sangre en la médula ósea
producen muchos glóbulos blancos
cancerosos que no funcionan
correctamente
esto debilita su sistema
inmunológico su médico establecerá un
plan de tratamiento específico para su
leucemia se basará en el tipo de
leucemia en sus síntomas en su edad en
su estado general de salud y en otros
factores las opciones de tratamiento
pueden incluir una o más de las
siguientes opciones quimioterapia
radioterapia terapia
dirigida
inmunoterapia y transplante de células
madre la quimioterapia usa medicamentos
que viajan a través del torrente
sanguíneo para matar las células de
rápido crecimiento tales como las
células
cancerosas otra opción de tratamiento es
la radioterapia utiliza radiación para
matar las células cancerosas o para
evitar que crezcan el área objetivo de
la radiación varía según la etapa y
según el tipo de
leucemia el tipo de radioterapia
utilizada para la leucemia Es la
radiación
externa utiliza una máquina que dirige
la radiación Al foco canceroso desde
fuera del
cuerpo la terapia dirigida utiliza
medicamentos que apuntan a objetivos
específicos o marcadores en las células
cancerosas como las células cancerosas
pueden tener más de estos marcadores que
las células normales la terapia dirigida
puede afectar más a las células
cancerosas que a las células normales
cuando los medicamentos de la terapia
dirigida se adhieren a los marcadores en
las células cancerosas las células
cancerosas pueden dejar de crecer y
dividirse la inmunoterapia puede ayudar
al sistema inmunológico a combatir la
leucemia por ejemplo los anticuerpos
monoclonales son versiones de proteínas
producidas en el laboratorio similares a
las que su sistema inmunitario produce
para combatir bacterias virus químicos y
otras sustancias extrañas los
anticuerpos monoclonales pueden
diseñarse para adherirse a marcadores en
las células de la leucemia y convertirse
en parte del sistema inmunol que ataca
la leucemia cuando se unen a las células
inmunitarias los anticuerpos
monoclonales pueden ayudar a reconocer y
a destruir las células leucémicas
un transplante de células madres
reemplaza las células formadoras de
sangre que fueron dañadas o destruidas
durante su tratamiento contra el cáncer
por células madres suyas o de un donante
sano primero se recolectan células
madres sanas suyas o de un
donante luego las células madres se
almacenan mientras recibe tratamiento
para el cáncer como quimioterapia o
radiación para destruir todas las
células
sanguíneas después de completar esos
tratamientos se administran las células
madre sanas en su cuerpo estas células
madre proporcionan un suministro
saludable de futuras células
sanguíneas el médico puede recetarle una
combinación de los tratamientos que
hemos discutido u opciones de otros
tratamientos mientras vive con su
diagnóstico de leucemia continúe
hablando con su médico y con el equipo
de atención médica contra el
cáncer